Політичні переслідування чи справедливе притягнення до відповідальності?
Петра Порошенка останнім часом почали особливо часто викликати у суди і на допити.
У чому обвинувачують п’ятогопрезидента України і що йому загрожує?
У липні 2018 року Порошенко своїм указом призначив першим заступником
голови Служби зовнішньої розвідки України Сергія Семочка,
проти якого нині порушено справи про незаконне збагачення і державну зраду.
Згідно з розслідуваннями журналістів, оприлюдненими після призначення Семочка,
його родина нібито володіє будинками вартістю близько 8 мільйонів доларів,
а родичі мають російські паспорти.
Петро Порошенко, як вважають у Державному бюро розслідувань,
у 2018 році схилив тодішнього голову Служби зовнішньої розвідки Єгора Божка
перевищення влади та видачі - цитата - "явно злочинного наказу",
за яким Семочко і заступив на свою посаду.
При цьому раніше, як писали ЗМІ, Порошенку готували іншу підозру
із зовсім іншими формулюваннями:
мовляв, призначення СемОчка на посаду нібито вчинено з метою захоплення влади.
Крім того, начебто мало місце зловживання владою
і при призначенні незаконної зарплати Семочка.
Якщо такі обвинувачення будуть доведені,
Петру Порошенку загрожує позбавлення волі на строк від 7 до 10 років.
У травні цього року Державне бюро розслідувань викликало Петра Порошенка
для допиту як свідка у кримінальному провадженні
про переміщення через кордон України з нібито приховуванням
від митного контролю 43 картин відомих художників.
Тоді Порошенко на допит не прийшов.
Натомість влаштував у Музеї Івана Гончара виставку цих картин, які проходять у справі.
Співробітники ДБР теж прийшли до музею, за їхніми словами,
щоб вручити Порошенку повідомлення
про виклик на допит. Стався конфлікт.
Музейники кажуть про пошкодження приміщення.
А силовики - про перешкоджання проведенню слідчих дій.
Справа про картини й надалі розслідується.
Порошенко запевняє, що картини були придбані
та ввезені в Україну легально і ще до його президентства.
Скільки порушено справ, де фігурує Порошенко, точно невідомо.
Цього достеменно не знають навіть адвокати п'ятого президента України.
За різними даними, точно понад 10.
Чимало справ про причетність Порошенка ініціює
колишній заступник голови Адміністрації президента часів Януковича Андрій Портнов.
Зокрема про спробу українських кораблів
пройти через Керченську протоку в 2018-му році.
Це стало першим випадком неприхованої агресії Росії на морі.
Порошенка обвинувачують у державній зраді і перевищенні влади,
бо він, мовляв, свідомо віддав наказ морякам
про походження протоки, щоб ескалювати ситуацію.
Також є справа про Вищу раду правосуддя, згідно з якою Порошенко
начебто перевищив службові повноваження, щоб призначити двох членів цієї ради,
яка здійснює нагляд за діяльністю суддів в Україні.
ДБР також намагалося викликати експрезидента України на допит
і щодо так званих "плівок Деркача", які начебто свідчать
про вплив колишнього віцепрезидента США
Джо Байдена на Петра Порошенка.
П’ятого президента України також підозрювали у причетності до присвоєння
званих "мільярдів Януковича", але потім справу закрили.
Крім того, як стверджує адвокат Порошенка Ілля Новіков,
в Офісі генпрокурора готують ще дві кримінальні справи
проти п'ятого президента України за начебто "хуліганство"
у лютому минулого року під час поїздки до Запоріжжя і Червонограда.